so let's just jump right into this first
story says from The Washington Post
Trump plans to turn himself in for
arraignment Tuesday reports The
Washington Post I mean that's basically
it they say um uh former president Trump
plans to fly to uh from Florida to New
York on Monday before appearing in a
specially secured Manhattan Courthouse
to be arraigned on still unspecified
criminal charges people briefed on the
arraignment said Trump is not going to
Hole up in Mar-A-Lago his lawyer Joe
takapina said Friday a day after news
the Manhattan grand jury is indictment
broke so I guess I guess the question
here is how do they even do this like
he's going to have to be released on
bail on his own recognizant so they're
not going to put him in jail what a
secret service going to go in jail with
him well it's going to be it's never
happened in the history of our country
in our 250 years as a republic this has
never happened before but from my
understanding Secret Service is taking
lead on this process so they've been
working with the NYPD uh and so on
Tuesday he's going to be arraigned and
uh I don't know what that's going to
look like but uh it's it's terrible this
is happening happening in our country it
says third world crap this is a Banana
Republic now
um but I gotta say they're going to
regret that putting that guy on a mug
shot can you imagine the t-shirts that
are going from that one of the stories
we'll get to later is um
how Joe Biden is going to spend the rest
of his days with Hunter Behind Bars
because they set the precedent but
you've also got that Mackie guy who made
a meme in 2016. he just got convicted
formally by uh I think was a jury right
and there's a woman who did the same
thing he did and she got no charges and
what he did was he made a meme that said
text instead of going to vote text your
vote to this number which was a false
thing and so they're like hey you can't
make people find a single victim and
then but the girl did the exact same
thing hey instead of voting for Trump
and don't wait in long lines text this
number with your vote she didn't post a
number though but she did say text
voting is legitimate so I'm saying we're
already in it we are absolutely in it
100 and you know on January 6 all the
people that brought a trump flag to the
Capitol and peacefully protested they're
spending years and years behind bars but
uh just a couple of days ago
trans-surrectionist storm state capitals
across the country and uh they're never
going to see a day in jail and not only
that but they attacked cops there's
videos of them pushing and fighting with
cops and there was a shaman although I
I'll back those guys those guys up on
the rights I'm saying guys for men and
women and everybody everybody's guys in
my opinion that's how I talk but like it
didn't seem VI I wouldn't call Violet
when the politicians came into the this
is in Tennessee the one I saw uh the
cops grabbed people to move them out of
the way there's a little pushing and
pulling I didn't see any blood I didn't
see anyone striking anyone so I support
your right to protest I didn't see any
police throwing flashbags into the
crowds or tear gas in these innocence
it's not just about that it's about the
protesters were holding up seven fingers
as a protest sign which signifies that
the perpetrator of the mass shooting was
a victim
that like you are in a cold Civil War
and I don't even know if it's fair to
call it cold because the power of the
federal government is being wielded to
beat people on the right into submission
it is it is the weight of of executive
Authority crushing down on people so I
don't think it's I don't think it's fair
to call it cold I think we have seen
physical confrontations we have seen
death we saw the far left try to to burn
down the White House burn down St John's
Church and we saw even with January 6
the fighting on one side like the
conflict is hot it's happening it's just
not like people are people are so
ignorant to history of the world they
expect there to be a formal declaration
by Virginia
Civil War and then for New York to be
like we are mobilizing our troops to
fight you and then they March down the
street towards each other what do they
think war is I don't know I think Jack
some jack pesobic some this week up
pretty pretty well he said this week
they indicted their top political
opponent convicted a descendant and one
one of their nuts shot up a school full
of Christian children and that's just
one week and it's so true that's what's
happening I mean they threw a guy
they're trying to put a guy who made a
meme mocking Hillary Clinton and believe
me there's a lot of material there to
mocker with but they they're throwing
this guy in prison they're trying to
throw him in prison for making a
freaking me and and every single person
needs to be speaking out in defense of
Douglas Mackey every journalist I saw
some journals that were giddy about this
guy being indicted these are the people
that are supposed to protect the First
Amendment and care about issues like
this but they're celebrating a guy who
mocked a political figure for going and
they wanted to go to jail what's what's
the legality if I stood outside of like
a voting place in totally legal it's
shut down today guys go home the
legality doesn't matter obviously and
clearly well what he did was tell them
instead of don't go vote instead just
texting it doesn't matter because anyone
he posted a meme to like nobody on the
internet so what is a legality can I
stand outside of a voting station and
tell people it's closed today everyone
goes
absolutely just make sure you register
as a Democrat before I mean I'm being
serious is it legal or illegal to do you
cannot go to an individual and and lie
to them to trick them into not vote okay
that's my question and that's what this
person you're right he didn't go to an
individual and there were no victims
okay and there was a woman who was a
Democrat who did the exact same thing
who wasn't charged so I'm I don't want
I'm not interested in hearing any
arguments about it he's going to jail
for election interference right you want
to talk about election interference the
left is concerned about election
interference that they want to throw a
memer in jail but they're celebrating
corrupt and obese Alvin Bragg for
throwing the top you know trying to
throw the top political opponent in jail
that's election interference if we're
talking about election interference not
some guy who made a meme that barely
anybody saw and said these people are
sick uh and they try them in Brooklyn
right no conservative is going to get a
fair Shake in Brooklyn no concern is
going to get a fair Shake in D.C and
they're going to convict him it's
terrible that's what's happening and
then they're gonna and they're gonna
push for jail time because they're
saying it's 34 counts they're going to
move for like they are going to try to
put him the reason they're doing at the
state level is because he can still run
for president he can still win the
presidency and if it was a federal crime
which the FED said there's no we can't
try him for this then he'd be able to
Pardon himself
but it's a state level crime so they
lock them up they lock them up Alex I
wanted to follow up and ask you about
this there's been interesting reactions
um to this indictment across the
political Spectrum one from Governor Ron
DeSantis whose tweet reads the
weaponization of legal uh the legal
system to advance a political agenda
turns the rule of law on its head it is
Un-American he says the Sorrows back
Manhattan D.A has consistently bent the
law to downgrade felonies and to excuse
criminal conduct yet now he is
stretching the law to Target a political
opponent and then most interestingly at
the end of his tweet he says Florida
will not assist in the extradition in an
extradition request given the
questionable circumstances at issue with
thesaurus backed Manhattan prosecutor
and his political agenda can I get your
reaction to this yeah so that second
part we'll start the second part that's
that's a not even an issue like that's
not even a part of the discussion and
that's just him trying to get some
attention out of this uh you know this
stuff for for his own political game but
the first part of it it his strong
statement came after uh you know 48
hours
of you know attacks like because when it
first was reported he was completely
silent and then when he finally opened
his mouth about it that Monday his
Consultants had him read this script to
at a press conference and a planted
question
and he says that it's a sideshow he said
he's not going to be distracted by a
circus he said he's focused on Florida
then he traveled to whatever state to
sell his book but he only responded
because he had so much outside pressure
and he had you know it was terrible for
him in the polls he started going down
in the polls after do you think that
response second part is bait whereas he
says Florida will not assist in an
extradition request given the
questionable circumstances that issue
with the sorospact Manhattan prosecutor
and his again I think that is simply
just him trying to save face and try to
get some publicity for himself out of
this movement that there's not even been
a conversation about that and he had a
lot of the DeSantis uh influencers who
don't influence much that were pushing a
narrative about how you know descent if
Trump really wants to fight the
political persecution he should take a
stand and listen to DeSantis and and
refuse to be extradited and I think
that's just so foolish the Soros DA's
are it's popular to attack them nowadays
he's mentioned Soros twice in this tweet
any thoughts on that yeah I'm no fan of
Soros and Soros waited on the 2024
election he said that he believes Ron
DeSantis will be the nominee and will
cause Trump to go into some uh
narcissistic induced state so you know
Soros is a is a guy that we have to pay
attention to and do something about I
don't think that a foreign-born
individual should be able to pay for
State prosecutors and have them do the
bidding of the political party that he
wants what's the is he's paying
companies to pay the pros to get the
prosecutors packs that's how you have
non-profits an individual can't just pay
a million dollars to a candidate so what
he does is there there are a variety of
super Pacs and packs political action uh
committees what is it political action
committee yes he can give as much money
as he wants to them and then they
campaign on your behalf the Only Rule
for super Pacs is that they don't
collude with the candidate it's like a
free speech ruling which is just crazy
because it's a secondary Campaign which
of course can do everything to get you
elected and you can funnel as much money
as you want into them they're not
supposed to collude but they do with the
Winking and odd yeah but I mean Soros
plays every game he doesn't just focus
on the the national politics he's at the
state levels he's at the local levels
and that's why conservatives and and
people who care about our country need
to be paying attention to every single
race and so there's a race that every
American needs to be paying attention
about right now it's the Wisconsin
Supreme Court race uh where a guy named
justice uh Dan Kelly is running for the
Supreme Court there uh Scott Pressler
give him a shot he's been doing really
great work on the ground in Wisconsin
turning out the vote uh but we you know
we need that Wisconsin Supreme Court
case uh sorry Wisconsin Supreme Court
seat uh pretty badly because if we don't
get it we're going to fall into another
Soros uh judge Soros gave a million
dollars to help this Democrat get
elected to the Supreme Court uh in
Wisconsin so he's focused at every level
of government and we're seeing the
consequences of that right now where
conservative billionaires are uh you
know not so focused on anything except
for again Ron DeSantis uh enough money
to try to beat Trump in the mega
movement you know it's very concerning
that if anyone even an American can can
give just push buttons and send hundreds
of millions of dollars to other people
to go do political work for them like
that's like a hijacking of our politics
system we're supposed to be for the
people no no no no no no no no no you
can you can use your resources to
promote ideas that you want to see
spread around anything any any kind of
limit on that is a limit on the freedom
of speech because you have the right
right to hire people and engage in
Commerce and engage in activity in
society this is this is Citizens United
that's the argument that's made the the
argument with the Supreme Court found
that citizens united or in the citizens
united case was that you had the right
to have an organization to promote your
ideas that your property as in your
money you could use your property to
promote your ideas and that's what
citizens united is so if you want to
start a foundation or or something like
that and you want to go ahead and have
some kind of organization that promotes
ideas that's the Heritage Foundation
that's Cato that's the center for
American progress It's all kinds of
things yes and it matters yeah that's
that's yeah it's totally me
I mean and and I I absolutely detest
like what Media Matters is trying to
promote right absolutely they're
communist they're awful I think and I
think that if they got their way they
would literally destroy the United
States I think that's their intent they
are ill-liberal authoritarians but it
doesn't mean that we can say well shut
them down you can't do that I'm not in a
not in a free country I have a personal
problem with citizens united I don't
like it I don't like that you can put
unlimited amounts of money into politics
and in the beginning of the Republic you
couldn't stop it what do you mean you
could you always could no it was when
someone was like taking Whistle Stop
dreams like why can't I spend my own
money campaigning for myself I'm like
well he's got a point and then other
people would do the same thing the
newspapers would be like we endorse this
person and we're going to put all of our
resources to getting them elected we're
gonna put them on the front page it was
it's never been any different there was
a challenge to a Citizens United and
Supreme Court was like it's your dollar
you you can speak and also another thing
that I want to point out like you hear
Democrats that have a lot of problem
with citizens united they're always the
ones that complain about it and since
citizens united you've had Barack Obama
then you had one uh one term of of
Donald Trump and then Joe Biden so it's
not that citizens united means that
conservatives or or May and maybe it
does mean the corporations because the
corporations are in bed with the
Democrats nowadays but it doesn't mean
that it's automatically going to be
conservative ideas or that it's going to
be uh uh the oligarchy of the the the
church being in in charge so far it's
been Democrats well we were talking
about you know Matt Gates before we we
launched the show here but Matt Gates
takes zero dollars from special interest
groups or packs he's was the first
Republican politician to say I don't
want your money yeah Barack Obama spent
more money than anyone ever and then
Hillary Clinton did the same thing and
Donald Trump didn't spend more money
than everyone and he still won you know
so so what makes money what makes me a
big fan of these Mega politicians from
president Trump to Matt Gates is they
would rather have small dollar donations
from hard-working Americans than go and
kiss the asses of the club for gross of
the world who receive you know 200
million dollars from five people and
then they have to take marching orders
president Trump when he ran in 2020 53
percent of his dollars came from small
dollar very small dollar donors thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time